what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Stone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters
Sophia yes you guys that silence is
something and that silence means cinee
is not here today
and that's a big deal cuz cinee it would
take a lot for her not to show up for a
podcast episode and we've actually had
to reschedule this session twice because
of her sickness but it all came crashing
down from last night I'm on the couch
and the phone starts ringing and I hear
literally sinee shaking through the
phone and all I hear is turn on the tub
make it scorching hot so that I can sit
in it because I'm freezing she's never
asked me to do that before in my life
and I we have a tub in the you know we
should be utilizing it more I'm just not
a tub girl I think sitting in their own
bath water is a little gross but she
loves it so I turned it on she gets in
and she was cold you could tell like
from her pale face that she was not
doing well and let's just say the rest
of the night just gets progressively
worse I swear to God she had the fevers
the aches the chills the whole shebang
like she was in pain I felt so sorry for
her so I got to put on my nurse hat and
that's what I did the whole night and
when I say nurse I was I was running
errands let's just say at 9900 p.m. last
night it is 20° out in New York it is
snowing it's freezing I actually think
when I was running out to go grab her
some hydration packets also she's very
specific about things she wants when
she's sick she wanted these what was it
Gatorade zero blue chill anything else
if it was like not Arctic chill she
would freak out it had to be zero
Gatorade Arctic chill actually she just
ordered some red ones to the apartment
and I can guarantee you she's not going
to be drinking those cuz that guy that
postm it here that was an acent so I'm
running at 1 p.m. to get all these
hydration packets not only that I'm
subbing wet towels I've left in the
refrigerator for her back and her neck
as she's sweating out filling up the hot
tub playing '90s romcom music in the
background trying to make her laugh and
even just this morning alone I ordered
her some like fresh pressed Orange Hot
Bagels I I have to say I'm a pretty damn
good nurse that sounds fabulous if
someone was doing that for me on any day
of the week I would just pretend I was
sick the whole entire time I mean I was
saying to cinee and just even my mom
this morning that when someone gets sick
you honestly realize whether or not
you're a good caretaker if you have like
a very maternal nature you know because
I feel like at my core because I have
friends by the way one of my girlfriends
was talking about her boyfriend being
sick a couple weeks ago and she was
explaining how annoyed she was about how
she had to take care of him how he was
just couldn't get out of bed she just
hated that she had to make him toast and
get him on his medicine rotation and
it's okay she wasn't complaining to him
but she was complaining to me but I
think that when you're caught in the
situation where this person genuinely
needs your help it's almost like a fight
ORF flight mode you're either going to
fly away and you're just not going to
deal with it and let them deal with the
Tylenol Advil PM NyQuil rotation that
they have to be on or you're going to
get out your imaginary PhD that you got
in nursing school and put that up front
because you know with cine specifically
I I'm I would say I'm a caretaker
naturally I would say I'm maternal but
my thing that I kind of do is I'm a bit
more rational I'm kind of like a robot I
I don't I would not I wouldn't say I'm
hugging you I'm not I'm not I'm not like
rubbing your back oh like don't worry
don't worry like that's just not me I'm
more of the person I see you and I think
okay problem equals solution okay what
are we going to do I'm I'm definitely
not going like get up sweetheart get out
of bed let's like get you into the tub
I'm going get in the tub get the ice
packs I'm going downstairs getting your
medicine if that if those two pills that
I left by your bedside aren't taken in
the next four minutes I'm going to take
them away and you're going to be sick
the rest of the night and I will say I
know look look I swear I am sympathetic
I'm sympathetic I I feel for her
and I this is going to sound really bad
um I think the worst part about a
roommate being sick is the potential
that you're going to get sick that's the
worst part right like I think that when
someone get sick you're going to put in
all this effort to make sure they're
okay and then you're always around them
and as many times as you wash your hands
I swear to God you're going to get it no
matter what I don't know what it is I'm
more I feel like I'm psycho like I'm
almost like not psychoanalyzing I don't
know what the word is but I'm almost
like tricking myself right now to
thinking I'm sick now even though I'm
totally fine but I feel like I can feel
the the germs on me I'm not I'm not OCD
with stuff like that but that's the
worst part so right now I'm nauseous
from the amount of zinc and vitamin C
I'm in taking every time I have a free
chance because I actually cannot get
sick I really can't I I cannot I mean
look I understand today's a holiday
we're shooting this on Monday it's going
to come out tomorrow so oh this is
probably the most real End Time episode
you're probably going to get this year
because we usually shoot a couple days
earlier but right now I'm doing it the
day before we're releasing so let's see
how this goes but yeah I I'm really
nervous that I'm going to get what cine
has and I'm looking at
her I don't want what she has right now
do you think you're good at taking care
of people Chris yeah I think I'm pretty
good at it I I agree with you the whole
like getting sick thing is kind of what
prevents me from wanting to do it more I
know if I was in your situation I was
like already there I'd be like okay
we're all going to get it you're not not
going to do it but then it's also I
think that added on fact that right now
it's freezing in New York it's like it's
snowing at this point and then being
sick on top of that cannot get any worse
maybe but maybe I'm wrong about that
maybe it's better that she's sick now
because she really can't go outside that
much there is nothing really worse than
being sick in the summertime it's like
everybody's enjoying the themselves
especially New York like everybody's
actually having a good time for once
slightly less miserable than but uh yeah
being sick is awful it's the worst and I
swear right now she just came back from
the doctor and she said that there's an
outbreak of influenza in New York and
actually not only that I'm not trying to
scare people right now but there's an
outbreak of not even just influenza of
covid too yeah so people have be getting
both the double whammy I swear to God if
she has both kill her I don't think so
though I think she just has flu and I
feel bad for her but I'm just
please for the love of God I cannot get
sick I cannot get sick but now I know
I'm a good mother I'm going to be a
tough mother I'm more of like the school
nurse I'd say I'm definitely like the
the movie school nurse that you don't
like in the movies because you know that
they're just like not warm but I get you
healed I put the Band-Aid on the wound
but I'm not I'm not going to be
swaddling you like feeding you with a
bottle making sure you're fine but if
anyone's going to get suem better it is
me okay so now that that's explained and
out of the way let's get into something
that I was actually really excited to
talk about this specifically because um
C and I have been going back and forth
about an obvious change to me currently
and I wanted her to be here to talk
about it but I guess I'll just kind of
say the obvious big news breaking news
after 10 long years of being a bleach
blonde I've decided to go brunette
thank you how do you feel I feel great I
will say I will say I looked at myself
in the mirror and it was definitely um
I've been doing a lot of double takes
and it's been a couple weeks and I still
don't recognize myself but at the same
time I'm a natural brunette like my my
natural hair is my root color so I kind
of feel like I also look like I'm 15
again I don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing but I changed my
hair because of a multitude of reasons I
don't know if I really got into it but
surface level reasons is because when
you've been dyeing your hair for 10
years bleach
especially it fries it off and you can
totally see when you talk to blondes you
have pieces are sticking up and I have
one of
those suei I was the ones with the
broken ends and also my hair was
naturally very thick and I saw that my
hair actually sine touched my hair and
it was probably the size of how I'm
holding my thumb and finger it was Tiny
compared to what it was before you had
to use your whole hand to feel how thick
my hair was so I was doing it because my
hair was falling off I was also bored of
seeing the same color for 10 years you
know I'm not someone that's a risk taker
I would say a lot of things in life I'm
risk adversed I kind of stay away from
anything that is a big change I just
don't like it I just I'm more of a
controlled person I like things that I
know are going to work out I already
knew that the blonde was going to work
out I knew that I didn't look good
brunette in the past so me doing this
big change was obviously I was pushed
against a wall and I was like I got to
do it now and it was to the point where
I had the idea and the feeling and I
booked the person the next day and I
just said here's a photo do it and I
don't want to see it until the end
because I don't want to say no and I
already knew the moment she started
putting in the toner that's when I
started to kind of freak out and I was
like I don't know if this is a good idea
this is a bad idea but I think also
innately I wanted to do this for a while
for some reason I've been saying this as
a joke for the last 10 years not 10
years 2 years I knew I wanted to go back
eventually but I didn't know when and I
knew it had to be a moment where I just
felt like this was the time also it's
just more fun to change it up you know
10 years of being a blonde also there's
a lot of brunettes in New York I'm
definitely not standing out so this is
definitely for me this is not me doing
it for someone else um but I've been
looking in the mirror and I don't
recognize this myself I was saying to
Chris that I look like I'm back to how I
was before
which kind of is sentimental I don't
know I don't know I kind of was like oh
I look like the old me again which is a
good thing in a way I guess I've matured
obviously but I think the main thing for
me was um you know the quote like hair
holds memories I ain't getting a bob
like there there my hair I've had a bob
before it's flown up I think you know
when your face can hold short hair so my
version of that is going brunette and
I'm like okay I've been this blonde for
10 years I feel like I've done
everything as a blonde and I kind of
wanted to go into a new phase and a new
year as a new color and you know I think
that sometimes there's a lot of changes
I want to do this year and sometimes I
feel like it's easier to start
implementing those changes when you see
a physical change and you go oh this is
a new version that I'm working on this
year this is a new person and um I was
also realizing and I said this kind of
before last like I would say in last
October I started seeing things that
were kind of going downhill with me
physically like I as we know I moved to
a whole new city so from LA to New York
very very different places um I'm now
entering a single phase where I was with
someone for a year and then I wasn't um
and then you're getting adjusted to this
new environment with friends and urban
see I'm I'm waking up and instead of
seeing a tree I see someone working at
their desk at 7:00 a.m. wake waving at
me and I hear trash man at 2: a.m. so so
it's just a very very different
environment and also the reality show
coming out and I also think that there
was just other things in my life and
it's almost like that Ferris sper quote
if you don't stop and look around like
life moves pretty fast whatever I think
I totally just flip-flopped that life
moves pretty fast if you don't stop to
take a look it flies by and I think I
was kind of just running on autopilot
for the last year and so in October
everything just kind of freaked out my
body is very much a body that if
something doesn't feel right it
physically reacts like if I was in a bad
relationship I get rashes that's my
thing that's my thing that's my brand
but for this one specifically um I think
I was just over stressing myself
overdoing it with everything and I also
was probably not being aware of how I
was feeling internally and I think it's
hard to sometimes selfcheck when you're
trying to distract yourself a lot and
especially in New York where everyone is
on this hustle mentality
stopping and pausing is just not the
first thing on your plate to eat so for
me in October I came to a haul when I
had like the eggmen which I was joking
about on the podcast the eczema the
cystic acne the I had a lot of migraines
I was just feeling super lethargic all
the time and so me cutting out alcohol
in November was a part of that change
and so since then I would say I've only
had like and I'm also doing dry January
so a total since November I've probably
drank like three times like not that
much any more not because I'm trying to
cut back or trying to be sober but I
just am feeling a lot better and so with
all those changes and I want to also go
into this year you know more focused on
natural hair natural nails like
lessening my focus on dating and
implementing more time into projects
that I had last year um I figured why
not do that with my hair first because
that was kind of like the biggest
identity with me everyone knew me as
like Sophia the blonde like the labador
with the black cat cine and and this was
kind of just like that that shake that I
kind of needed to go okay this is the
the new version and I think that's
important that people need to do that
sometimes where I feel like especially
in your 20s you don't really ever pause
and think about okay so I've done all
these things is it making me happy like
a self check I feel like people don't
self check a lot maybe it's a little bit
more in this generation but I think that
sometimes especially when you're you
know trying to like get involved D and
you know when you're in your 20s you're
trying to figure yourself out you don't
really figure yourself out you're kind
of like doing everything but doing
nothing you know and so right now for me
I was able to stop and go like what is
going to make me filled and so that's
that and this is by the way when I said
I don't want to date cuz I said this in
my ins and out list I said that I was
dating not for just because I'm dating
for marriage which the said that was a
lot and I understand that also everybody
that I've told said that that's a little
bit heavy but you know I think that it's
Le it's less about marriage I'm not
trying to get hitched right now unless
unless you're a good one this finger
feeling this hands feeling a little
light right now um it's just more I'm
looking for quality not quantity so I'm
not going to put in time with someone
that I don't find you know that's going
to work for me also you know I just had
this Vision maybe this is going to help
look at life like a pie like an apple
pie right cine I totally I already can
Envision sine making fun of me for doing
this little metaphor life is like an
apple pie okay let's say it's cut into
four slices and one is for your energy
for friendships and social one is for
family one is for personal growth and
the other one is for let's just say
career right because that's also a big
part the reason why I'm not putting
anything into relationships is because
right now some of those pieces of the
pie are eaten a little bit more so they
kind of need to be refilled and I want
the whole pie to be done before you know
I give it freshly to someone else
because look I think a lot of people do
this and this is the problem especially
when you don't feel like you're whole
like where let's just say your career or
your purpose you can't find it and
you're feeling really insecure about it
so someone takes away that pie and you
look at someone and you shove a
blueberry pie and the apple pie it
doesn't work it doesn't fit No One's
Gonna buy that pie you're not going to
buy that pie it doesn't work right I
know it sounds really shitty and stupid
analogy but my point is is that you
can't force something to work unless
you're comfortable with yourself if
you're really looking for that one you
can absolutely just date for fun don't
get me wrong I think that's all a part
of the social life and figuring out what
you want but if you're in my position
where you've kind of done that and
you've dated and you like I look I'm
also a relationship person I'm not a one
night stand which power to you go at it
if you want to do that but for me I'm
not so
I just you know want to have that whole
thing filled and then I feel like once I
am at my best I can you know find
someone I kind of just went on a tangent
from brunette to blonde moment or blonde
to brunette but speaking of that let me
go into
this I've noticed a significant
difference in the way people treat me as
I was a blonde to a brunette and I've
watched the videos I've talked to the
Friends and I didn't believe it to be
honest I was thinking okay that's kind
of dumb like who really gets different
treatment from their hair color like I
the way my friends will treat me the way
the guys will treat me it's not
different no oh yeah oh yeah I see big
changes and I'll tell you a few and it's
not even been that long and look I love
being a brunette love it this I'm very
happy with how it turned out it's also
not fully brunette as you can see baby
steps there's some highlights in there
but
I would say being a blondee especially
in New York is like wearing a spotlight
on your head you know everyone's going
to kind of look at it if you're dressed
well and you're a blonde with long hair
people are going to double take you in
some way for some reason and I notice
that especially as I move to the city
right like do you feel like you kind of
like notice sometimes blondes more when
they're having their big hair and
they're walking down the street and
stuff like that right like what is that
movie star yeah something like I'm like
did you see me okay okay okay um no but
I noticed that and to be honest some of
the stairs for me when I was doing that
I got stared at this is not me being
cocky I'm not saying that everyone
looked at me and I'm a hot shot thanks I
mean look yeah people looked at
me um but and not all of them were like
not all of them were wanted but now
being a
brunette you guys like no one
looks no one I swear no one checks me
out even when I'm put together I swear
no one really looks at me and I and
that's not people will look but it's not
the same as when I was a blonde and I
will also say I will also say the
quality of the
conversation also the quality of the guy
is totally different totally different
when I was a blonde people would say the
most out of pocket stuff just the most
unnecessary things the craziest things
the craziest things I would say like I
mean other than calling me like ay
Malibu Barbie get your ass over what I'm
that's crazy crazy and then I would also
I mean also as a blonde like if I would
go to the bar I would get free drinks
way more often way more often also
unnecessary Taps and things like that in
my like it was just like no one had any
reservations when I was a blonde it was
the weirdest thing ever and I also feel
like when guys would hit on me the
conversations were very goofy in surface
level but and this is by way I'm also
not saying this is a good thing blondes
I was a blonde I was you so I get you
but as
brunette it's not as many guys will come
up to me like a blonde but the guys that
do it almost seems like a better quality
conversation like they kind of treat me
more seriously even like the meetings I
was just in La I just felt like I was a
boss in the room rather than just
someone that they could go oh she's a la
blonde girl you know like influencer do
you see what I'm saying and look I will
say this too being a blonde holds some
power because I mean the amount of ways
you can kind of control people with
being a hot blonde it's pretty damn cool
but I will say it's it's it's a
different world being a brunette in some
good ways and some bad ways because look
I'm not going to lie there's attention
and Cat calls sometimes I needed them
sometimes I was not having a good day
and I'm walking down the street and
someone double takes me and I'm like
still got it now I'm literally sitting
actually this is really funny I'm at
Whole Foods the other day I'm checking
out and there's this guy standing next
to me so cute and I will say I looked
pretty cute I didn't look
horrible I can tell you right now I know
if I was a blonde he would have looked
at that Spotlight on my head he would
have looked at it I even nudged him I
even stood at the checkout and nudged
him didn't even look over and walked
away and so I'm blaming the brunette or
he has a
girlfriend so you know what I'm going to
blame the girlfriend I'm not going to
say it's me but that's also that has
been the stuff that I've noticed and it
is just it's interesting So speaking of
guys um of course that's what we talk
about a lot in this episode but but we
said in the last episode that I was
headed to LA and cinee and scarl decided
to join last minute and I'm back from LA
and there's so many updates and I'll
just say this before I get into the
story and the lesson I learned there is
that I went to LA for work and it was a
really exciting project that I've been
working on and it's not the book that
I've been always talking about which is
almost done um but it's another thing
that I've been producing and writing and
let's just say it was successful I think
it's the brunette
I also think it's my brains and I just
I'm really really excited for this year
because you know it feels good when you
do something and you have you know a lot
of heart in a project and people respond
to it positively sometimes it it's it's
really hard to keep yourself motivated
when you've been working over and over
on something that you're passionate
about and you're not receiving any not
credit is probably not the right word
but just some response a positive
response and someone that wants to
further it with you and so can't really
talk too much about it but I will say
that it's all positive and I'm really
excited for 2024
but I learned a really big lesson and
this is involving because we're all
about positive selfworth in this 2024 as
I've been brunette and also I'm
encouraging everyone to make those big
changes because I will tell you right
now when you make big changes once it
kind of just follows suit like a lot of
things that you do like I feel like a
little bit rebellious with the whole
hair color change
and now being a certified nurse I really
feel like I'm qualified to tell people
do those changes and do what you want to
do I was in LA for work but I'm going to
scoot back a little bit New Year's Eve
we had said in the last podcast that I
got a peck from
someone let's call Mr LA because he
lives in La that's an easy way to say it
I feel like I'm copying every podcaster
but I don't really know what how else to
refer to so and by the way this pack
wasn't something I expected also it was
30 minutes after the countdown so it
doesn't count so I guess he was
technically My First Kiss of
2024 was it great I don't know it was
fine it was a peack so we we already had
each other's numbers I've known him for
a while this is just all about knowing
your gut this is a lesson about trusting
your gut because I will tell you right
now I'm headed into this 2024 year with
a good gut and reading reading the room
reading the emotions and going off of it
and I want people to start doing that
okay so so we've already been talking
I've known this guy for a really long
time like not not in a romantic way
we've always we matched on a dating up
years ago and so cut to now we've never
ever we've always been kind of text
friends but that's pretty much it and we
ended up this year New Year's Eve when
we pecked right he knew that I was
heading to LA in like seven eight days
right I'm answering his text messages
this boy proceeds to answer me probably
every 48
hours he's playing the long long game
he's playing some sort of game I would
answer pretty quickly and then he would
like clockwork answer every 24 to 48
hours and I was like okay and by the way
we've already kind of said to each other
we were going to go on a date so I was
kind of excited I'm like oh we can kind
of talk a little bit and cine kept
saying to me relax like who cares if
he's answering this that whatever but
for me I kind of was like I don't know
is it's kind of irking me there's
something it's annoying like I kind of
was like okay why isn't he you know
setting the time setting the place also
also that same night on New Year's Eve
his friend asked for Stine's number and
lives in La as well by day two he
already figured out the time place and
day that they were going to see each
other when I I'm talking to this guy who
I've known for much longer nothing so I
get to LA
and my purpose for being there my
purpose was to see my girlfriends and
also get my work done right so as Mr La
24-hour 40 hour game guy wasn't
answering I booked all my free times for
my girlfriends because that's what you
do you don't sit by the phone and wait
you just do what you got to do I leave
on Thursday Tuesday comes around and he
says book me in for Wednesday night and
I go sorry no too late see you next time
he proceeds to text me immediately for
the next day all over on time
247 old me probably would have retreated
and said oh yeah I'm free Wednesday
right but there was something might Gott
going no I always remember what my dad
said my dad always says this how someone
treats you early on is always how
they're going to treat you on later and
that stuck in my head and I was like you
know what
I don't want to go into
2024 waiting for someone to text me
wondering what he's thinking playing
these games if a guy wants to see me and
knows my value he's going to book a time
place and this is just how I roll may
not be for everyone it's not everyone's
piece of pie but that's my pie I'm all
about pies today who knows why maybe
I'll go pick up some after this anywh
who he actually this is kind of crazy I
end up going to dinner with my
girlfriend I find out a day or two later
by the way by the way if this is the
best part of all of this I ghost
him thank you thank you I did what he
did to me I ghost to him but I find out
I'd say maybe a couple days later that
this guy they said to basically they
said Sophia stay away from him you
should not be with him because every
girl he's ever dated he's made insane he
does this trick and I quote he leaves
girls on red plays mind games with them
over the phone makes them feel like
they're crazy and then they end up
leaving him and he gets over the
relationship within three days they
said moral of the
story trust your gut go
brunette no don't go actually join me
moral story is trust your gut you know
what you want you know what you expect
and you know what you're looking for so
please for this year ladies and
gentlemen we're not all here waiting by
the phone for someone to text us we're
all here waiting for someone to text us
the time day and place they want to see
us again and again and again because
it's not worth it to wait and I'm
telling you right now I trusted my gut I
listened to it I knew from the start
that there was something off and I'm so
glad that I stuck with it and it just
makes me feel good because I feel like
going into this year 2024 is off to a
good start hair body brain wise and this
is a mini episode so obviously I could
go on and talk because I love talking
for another hour but I'm not going to do
that to you guys and I guarantee s would
kill me in the editing room if she had
to edit a 50-minute episode I was only
me talking but thank you guys so much
for tuning in I hope you guys you know
got some little lessons and Tibbits and
some funny stories some laughs and
please please please please understand
this is my first solo episode I'm
nervous and I really wanted this to go
well so even if you hated it just don't
say it be kind in 2024 also say say look
at also if you pass me on the street
check me out all right I hope you guys
have a fabulous Tuesday and I will see
you next week with sinee bye